[Music]
[Music]
Wow hello it's Jen from insider and
today we are going to be making
miniature ramen using this kit from
poppin cookin the twist about this is
that it's actually all candy I'm not
sure how it's going to go because it
looks kind of complicated but with
picture instructions my limited
knowledge of Japanese and hopefully a
little bit of luck you'll be able to
create something really awesome
[Music]
so we have our little gyoza press here
works like that that's really cool we
have a little ramen bowl and we have
another mold for the tamago egg and a
Naruto fish cake very convenient
[Music]
whoo
oh my gosh I made a dumpling that's okay
[Music]
so we finished making the dough for the
ramen and we're gonna scoop it into this
piping bag that we got here make sure
that there's no air bubbles you don't
want to have chunky noodles I mean flick
the milski discriminate all noodles are
good noodles right see how it goes no
way
oh my gosh have you ever seen such a
satisfying needle pool in your entire
life this looks like real ramen
[Music]
[Music]
hey Becky my okay the noodles themselves
tastes like a limp wet noodle huh
but it looks so lifelike I can't be mad
so we have our dumpling here it's very
cute it looks exactly like something my
mom would make let's go
it is exactly like the Japanese soda
called Romina so they have a very
distinct soda flavor in Japan with a
little bit like citrusy bubblegum I
think it's definitely for a novelty kind
of experience I think this would be so
fun to do with like friends or if you're
babysitting and you want a fun thing to
do to keep the kids engaged it's
completely edible it's super easy to do
I definitely would buy this again I want
to try different other foods and see how
they put a twist on this because of the
experience of squeezing the noodles into
the broth and having it all everything
come together especially with these
little dumplings it's so satisfying
[Music]